the U.S Senate officially and
unanimously votes to make John fetterman
get dressed before coming to work at
these supposedly greatest deliberative
body in the world
a bipartisan resolution titled the show
our respect to the Senate act the shorts
act
s-h-o it was somewhat labored but they
call it the shorts act it was put
forward by Democrat Joe manchin and sort
of Republican Mitt Romney requiring that
male Senators wear a quote coat tie and
slacks or other long pants on the senate
floor or else risk removal by the
Sergeant at Arms the shorts Act is the
most productive legislative work that
the U.S Senate has done this term the
Senators can't figure out how to fix the
Border crisis or revive the economy or
even fund the government but they have
finally now at least figured out how to
dress themselves